[Music]
flowers are a valentine's day tradition
and while they come in many colors the
people who grow and deliver them
have the ryan plenty of green this year
they're celebrating the holiday plan to
spend an average of 196 dollars on
valentine gifts
total spending is expected to hit 27.5
billion dollars that is up 32 from last
year's record of just over 20 million
flowers are among the top three gifts
for the holiday but as nancy chen
reports getting millions of fresh
bouquets from growers to grateful
recipients requires
a monumental effort
everything's coming up roses lilies
and yes even carnations at this
warehouse
in queens new york the clock is ticking
and these bouquet creators are moving
swiftly
with february 14th just days away
how is this going to look coming up to
valentine's day well we won't have any
empty space like this it'll all be full
like we have over here
we're starting to bring the product in
this place will be blooming
chris mccann is the ceo of 1-800 flowers
one of the largest online gift retailers
this week
those same shelves have been filled with
bouquets
six thousand of them ready to be
delivered
across new york city roses are the big
one yeah out of 22 million stems that
will sell for valentine's day 14 million
will be roses
with families and loved ones separated
by the pandemic
the company as a whole anticipates
revenue growing
by about 50 percent this quarter so this
will be your biggest valentine's day
ever
we believe it will be second only to
mother's day in demand
valentine's day is synonymous with fresh
blossoms
and plenty of them the majority of these
blooms come from ecuador or columbia
home to nearly 65 percent of the flowers
in the u.s
it took a little more work to get us to
the point where we could actually make
roses bloom in february amy stewart is
the author of flower confidential a book
about the global flower industry
being able to get roses in the middle of
winter was very closely linked to
advances in transportation
first it was having rail cars and
automobiles that could get flowers from
farms to markets
and then it was airplanes to get them
from warm climates to cold climates
on thursday the last of the valentine's
day flowers were flown in
and processed at miami international
airport
the stems thoroughly inspected at
customs
amir pineda oversees the operation about
1.1 billion stems of flowers come
through
from the beginning of january through
february 15th
before continuing on to floors and
distributors around the country
all planned planted and primed for one
peak day
february 14th how difficult is it to
make sure that timing is just
right when we're bringing the flowers in
from the farms
we have ethylene gas inhibitors in there
to make sure that the gases
mix is proper for the flowers so there's
so much of a science that goes into this
i thought i was getting into a flower
business running one star
and then getting into this virtual
e-commerce business
what we've had to learn about logistics
and distribution of perishable products
has just been fascinating
the mccann family started with a single
flower shop in new york 45 years ago
before centering their brand
around 1 800 flowers as toll-free
numbers
took off now more than 5 000 of
america's finest florists have the same
telephone number
1 800 flowers then another game changer
so we started to dabble in e-commerce
back in 1991
with a platform i don't know if anyone
still remembers compuserve
we were the first merchant to sell any
product of any kind on aol in 1994.
taking that through the 2000s we just
rode the wave of e-commerce
their flowers now come from partner
farms as well as a network of 5
thousand floors nationwide the company
has expanded across 15 brands of gifts
including carrie and david in the
popcorn factory delivering to 160
countries
it hasn't always been a bed of roses
customer complaints about delayed
deliveries
and bouquets far from what their
pictures promised
have made the rounds on social media
things that didn't really show up
like they were advertised what went
wrong and when you're dealing with a
perishable product
sometimes you're going to have
challenges weather can pose a challenge
both extreme cold extreme heat composer
challenge
but the key is how we respond to that
and when you look at how customers are
reaching us these days
it's through social media we respond to
those messages on
social media within three to five
minutes on average
mccann points to that customer service
as their competitive edge
they also enterprise new concepts like
roses that last a year
and partnerships with celebrities like
fashion designer jason wu
constant innovation and a long tradition
where does the idea of gifting flowers
for valentine's day come from
because valentine's day is in february
it's not the easiest time to give
somebody flowers so
originally originally we sent paper
cards but it really wasn't until
greenhouse technology came along and
made it possible to make flowers bloom
in february
that that migrated over into valentine's
day and that was kind of the 1920s
steward says the idea of gifting
bouquets dates back to the ancient
romans
but the victorians in particular
embraced the language of flowers
using specific blooms to convey careful
messages
they couldn't otherwise sail out some of
those notes
endure today part of it is just
tradition it's really just embedded
in our um in our cultural awareness
there's not a culture anywhere in the
world that doesn't view flowers as this
kind of
romantic way of expressing a sentiment
and those feelings of affection are only
heightened
this valentine's day as we hold the
people we love
closer than ever at least in our hearts
if not always in person how do you think
this valentine's day is going to stack
up in the history of valentine's day's
4 1 800 flowers well in the history
books this valentine's day will
certainly have an asterisk as being a
very different one and we think it's one
of the most important valentine's days
about korea a day that's the culmination
of an incredible year-long
effort encompassing the work of many for
a simple message
between two for cbs this morning
saturday
nancy chen new york very nice
and i believe at the top of the show or
during promo you questioned whether
we were going to get you flowers whether
i was going to get you flowers i think
it's from youtube
i will say yes that's true it was a team
effort but let me
shout out to denia who prepared these
for you
and as you take them home you guys i'm
sure you know this already but cut the
stems before you put them in the vase
and use flower food they're beautiful
right well you know it's
funny i've been to otavalo in ecuador
and
my husband bought me a 24
pack of flowers actually
that's two dozen yes guess how much he
paid for him
a buck
it really is it's the markups incredible
by the way sean grandy not off the hook
you're not off the hook still
valentine's day tomorrow that's all i'm
saying